es ist verrückt die hubble konstante
wurde neu berechnet und das kann unser
ganzes weltbild durcheinander werfen sie
belag nämlich wie schnell sich das
weltall ausdehnt und davon hängt eine
menge ab click the pics weltall
expandiert die sogenannten cluster also
galaxienhaufen driften immer weiter
auseinander
und je weiter sie von uns entfernt sind
desto schneller scheinen sie das zu tun
um dieses phänomen zu beschreiben wurde
die hubble konstante bestimmt sie sagt
aus wie groß die rate der expansion des
weltraums
allerdings ist diese konstante nicht
wirklich konstant ihr wert ja der pendel
je nach berechnung um eine bestimmte zu
halten und je nachdem wie diese zahl
aussieht beschreibt wie ein anderes
weltall umso exakter wir sie kennen
desto mehr wissen wir über materie
dunkle materie und dunkle energie
schätzungen zufolge sollte die konstante
bei 67 8 kilometern pro sekunde pro
megabyte
ein megaparsec wird dabei um drei
millionen lichtjahre allerdings kam
letztes jahr ein forschungsteam mit
hilfe des hubble-weltraumteleskops auf
73 kilometer pro sekunde pro megabyte
forschung hat nun eine neue methode
entwickelt um die hubble konstante zu
berechnen
dazu bedienen sie sich eines effekt und
wartest gravitationslinseneffekt
forscher der hano leykauf coloration h0
steht dabei für die hubble konstante bei
dem deutsche wissenschaftler vom max
planck institut für astrophysik der
universität bonn und der lmu in münchen
mitarbeiten machen sich also die
tatsache zunutze dass große massen die
zum beispiel sternenhaufen eine raum
krümmung bewirken die wehrpflicht
ebenfalls ab lenkt das licht von
objekten hinter diesen matten nimmt
seinen unterschiedlich langen weg bis
von messgeräten ausgewertet wird
aus diesen verschiedenen zeitmessung
antifa waren haben die forscher nun
einen neuen wert für die hubble
konstante
ermittelt wie kommen auf einen wert von
71 9 kilometern pro sekunde pro
mega-party durch weitere suche soll die
genauigkeit des wert noch verbessert
werden
sehr interessant sind die erkenntnisse
und auch die abweichung für ältere
menschen wenn es um dunkle energie geht
es könnte sich herausstellen dass auf
kosmologische standardmodell einer
überholung bedarf wenn wir eine neue
physik im weltall brauchen apropos neue
physik zum ersten mal wurde ein
bose-einstein-kondensat also ein riesen
atom im weltall erfolgt klickt hier wenn
er das thema genauso spannend findet wie
ich und kein video mehr verpacken dafür
hier kostenlos abonnieren und die glocke
anklicken dann verpackt er wirklich
nicht mehr den daumen nach oben wenn ihr
wollt das video loben
ja und was glaubt ihr was sich hinter
dunkle energie verbirgt schreibt sie mir
in die kommentare und ansonsten bis
morgen und